merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre l'industrie vendredi dernier le
tribunal de commerce de Lyon a prononcé
la liquidation judiciaire du groupe
place du marché expo par gel qui emploie
plus de 1900 salariés sur 127
plateformes en France le site le plus
important en termes d'emploi est celui
d'Argentan dans l'Orne avec près de 90
salariés vous imaginez bien que cette
liquidation est un véritable coup de
massue à la fois pour les personnels qui
voient leur vie bouleversée en quelques
jours et à la fois pour le territoire
d'Argentan qui a encore une économie
fragile suite à une désigne de
réalisation massive dans les années 2000
à l'initiative du préfet de l'Orne une
réunion réunissant le mandataire les
représentants du personnel les élus
locaux Pôle Emploi les services de
l'État a été organisé hier afin de faire
le point sur les mesures mises en place
collectivement et individuellement pour
les 1900 salariés un PSE dans le cas de
la procédure plan grand licenciement va
donc être déclenché toutefois il a été
précisé lors de ce rendez-vous qui
n'était pas prévu d'indemnisation supra
légale cette nouvelle a été très mal
vécue par les salariés qui se sentent
trahis et humilié alors qu'ils ont fait
des efforts considérables pour relever
l'entreprise même lorsque le tribunal a
constaté qu'il n'y avait pas de
repreneur les salariés ont jusqu'à la
fin et malgré la fermeture annoncée
préparer les produits classés et mis sur
palette afin qu'ils puissent être
valorisés financièrement par le
liquidateur il est donc impératif
monsieur le ministre de trouver un moyen
de réparer cette injustice et d'obtenir
des indemnités supra légales pour ses
salariés qui en plus vont certainement
être les premiers à être concernés par
la réduction des indemnités chômage dans
le temps pour cela nous avons besoin que
le gouvernement fasse pression sur les
actionnaires afin qu'ils abondent soit
le PSE soit la trésorerie pour verser
ses indemnités cette demande est
d'autant plus légitime que les deux
actionnaires principaux Léo et Patrick
va Dorian sont notamment à la tête de
l'enseigne florissante grand frais qui
dégage suffisamment de bénéfices depuis
des années pour permettre au moins ce
geste vis-à-vis de leur 1900
collaborateurs qui laissent aujourd'hui
sur le carreau monsieur le ministre
pouvons-nous compter sur le gouvernement
et sur vous pour aider les sites
notamment dans l'Orne réindustrialiser
et pour accompagner les salariés et
essayer d'obtenir ces indemnités suivra
légales